[Música]
bueno pues vengo a platicarles sobre la
problemática de desechos sólidos cuando
vemos esta foto pues se nos vienen a la
mente muchos problemas realmente
pensemos qué pasa con los empaques y con
las cosas una vez salen de nuestra mano
y una vez salen de su vida útil y cómo
llegamos a este punto de la basura
dentro de esto tenemos diferentes
realidades diferentes infraestructuras
que funcionan detrás pues si yo vengo a
hablarles un poco qué pasa con la parte
de los empaques vamos a hablar un poco
sucio
pero de realidad tenemos empaques con un
alto valor post consumo empaques con
bajo valor que es positivo es decir
empaques que la gente está incentivada
colectar y llevar a esos mecánicos para
volver a darle otra vida útil al
producto y volver a reconvertirlo en un
empaque pero hay productos que no tienen
un alto dolor post consumo y qué pasa
con nuestros productos y son desechados
y vectores si la industria no está
incentivada porque no existe una
infraestructura económica detrás de
estos empaques para poder ser
recolectados y pensemos en realmente qué
está pasando en este vertedero hablemos
un poco de la industria de los empaques
desde 1950 se considera que empieza el
boom de la industria de empaques como
hoy lo conoce es un empaque de texas
de mil novecientos cincuenta mil 15
vemos que la el crecimiento es
exponencial y eso por lo general
conlleva otro problema la afectación de
basura es exponencial conforme va
creciendo la necesidad de embalaje la
globalización ha traído mucha necesidad
de empaque y eso ha producido mucha
basura
aquí tenemos un ejemplo de el 2000 al
2050 de cómo se debería de ver el futuro
de materiales y vemos que la humanidad
está tratando de dejar de depender de
materiales vírgenes y empiezan a
integrar en sus infraestructuras de
empaques embalajes reciclados o
reciclables
pero también nace una categoría nueva
que es todo lo que es a base de plantas
y todo lo que es compostable y bio
basado y entonces en pie empezamos a
encajar un concepto muy importante que
es la bioeconomía circular
que están los gobiernos a nivel
internacional prohibiendo los plásticos
de un solo uso
ante la falta de conocimiento de que se
puede hacer en materiales para que se
vuelvan a reintegrar a los suelos y para
que se puedan volver a reciclar están
prohibiendo los ejemplos nuevos que
tenemos desde hace menos de un año
méxico-china como uno de los países
relevantes en la prohibición de
plásticos de un solo uso chile-ecuador
caribe eeuu etcétera etcétera esto hace
dos años era la mitad de lo que ustedes
están viendo acá en provisiones y en
regulaciones así que esta es una
tendencia irreversible
estamos tratando todos de encontrar una
solución a este problema gobiernos
industria consumidores
y aquí es donde nace un concepto todo
mundo conoce el reciclaje
la economía popular es decir algo que
mecánica regresa un proceso para
reconvertirse en un material utilizable
y que entra en un circuito cerrado pero
también existe la viva economía circular
y la bioeconomía circular es en lugar de
usar un proceso mecánico para reciclar y
volverle a dar vida útil a un a un
producto se usa la naturaleza o la
tierra como catalizador natural entonces
son productos que son capaces de
reintegrarse a los suelos y volverse a
reconvertir en un producto renovable
para volver a hacer un empaque esa es la
idea detrás de todo el concepto y cuando
mezclamos estos dos conceptos sale la
cuerda la bioeconomía circular y eso es
el diálogo que más está haciendo
sentidos para resolver esta problemática
de desechos sólidos
vemos que en la industria es donde más
está funcionando el reciclaje porque se
pueden hacer rutas inversas de
recolección de material utilizable para
reciclar es decir aprovecho a cuando voy
a dejar la leche o el papel etcétera a
recolectar material en la misma ruta y
lo vuelvo a reintegrar en un impacto y
eso está funcionando muy bien pero el
hogar es una ecuación más complicada
porque el consumidor cotidiano no sabe
la diferencia entre un pp entre un ps
entre un hay infinidad de materiales que
no son compatibles uno con el otro y
aquí es donde empieza a hacer sentido
integrar este tipo de materiales no
nocivos para el medio ambiente y
hablemos un poco de la fuente de dónde
salen estos materiales son suelos tapis
hoy por hoy aquí hay un estadístico
interesante de los bioplásticos para el
2024 plásticos representan el 0.02 por
ciento del total del suelo arable
así que hoy por hoy no es una por uno es
un problema para la canasta básica no
están quitando grado alimenticio para
estar en esta en esta rama de
bioplásticos y aparte de eso estamos
viendo que se están integrando rechazos
y desperdicios de materiales para entrar
en una cadena realmente responsable de
materiales que hoy por hoy se consideran
como un rechazo pero que se puede
convertir en un insumo de empaque y aquí
es donde empieza el tema interesante qué
pasa con el reciclaje
no es la única solución es una de las
soluciones pero para tener este diálogo
avanzado y encontrar este problema
tenemos que aportar todos en muchas
áreas y muchas aristas aquí es una
muestra del 98 por ciento del material
virgen que se produce a nivel mundial
que se traduce en 78 millones de
toneladas de polímeros
más del 80% cuando se desecha termina en
cadenas no cerradas es decir en
vertederos aeróbicos y no aeróbicos en
cuerpos de agua y ambientes que no
queremos que termine la basura y 14% se
incinera para recuperación energética
eso sí se considera como un ciclo
cerrado pero lo interesante de esto es
que si ustedes ven todo el proceso lo
único que regresa a reconvertirse el
empaque es 2 % es muy poco es muy poco y
yo sé hay empresas que hacen esfuerzos
mayores a eso pero esta es la
estadística general nos guste o no nos
guste
entonces qué es un bioplástico está
hecho a base de materiales renovables
sobre todo ahora que se están empezando
a rechazos consumido por microorganismos
como fuente de energía y alimento es
decir todo el concepto detrás de esto es
cómo hacemos para que la bolsa o el
empaque o el de embalaje se convierta en
alimento para un microorganismo y no
deja rastro de toxinas y dioxinas eso es
muy importante también para compaginar
con todo el concepto y hoy por hoy esto
es una muestra de productos que ya
existen en el mercado que compiten
contra alternativas convencionales esto
no es no es un sueño esto ya está
pasando hoy y pues esto lo que se busca
hacer es crear conciencia sobre este
nuevo término y esta nueva categoría de
empaques para para que tengamos un poco
mayor cultura en la parte de desechar
nuestros productos y escoger nuestros
embalajes
y aquí es una muestra de qué es lo que
pasa un microorganismo realmente lo que
estamos haciendo es insertar glucosa a
nivel molecular a una estructura de
embalaje y eso se traduce a alimentos
energía o fuente de carbón para una
bacteria o para un hongo y el hongo a
través de digestión enzimática logra
absorber esa energía y desechar biomas
eso es lo que está pasando detrás del
mundo de los bioplásticos y aquí hay una
foto real de bolsas y en lo que se
convierte después de una actividad
microbiana o de un consumo microbiano
y aquí a simple vista tenemos como el
hongo va colonizando el material porque
encuentra fuente de carbono de energía
encuentra alimento en el material y eso
lo está utilizando de comida y empieza a
colonizar el material hasta que logra
digerirlo todo en su integridad y cuando
logra digerirlo todo se pasa a otro
cuerpo que te contenido de glucosa y ahí
va digiriendo ese es la cadena
alimenticia de un microorganismo
también se han hecho pruebas de estudios
de qué impacto tienen los suelos en la
tierra si realmente tiene un impacto en
eco toxicidad o toxinas en los suelos y
ahí se hacen pruebas de si se acelera
así que si si para de crecer la planta
lo que sucede en el ambiente natural
cuando cuando uno de estos embalajes
termina en un cuerpo o en un ambiente
que no deseamos
y no espero que todos se vuelvan
expertos en el tema esto es un mundo muy
complejo esto es una pequeña muestra de
los materiales principales bio basados
que existen en el a nivel mundial y lo
que ven alrededor es los diferentes
entornos o ambientes en el que el
producto se puede descomponer es un
mundo súper complejo y a mí me gusta
compararlo con las reglas del fútbol
americano
todos sabemos cómo se puede el punto
americano pero es súper complejo y es lo
mismo exactamente pero hay apasionados
por el tema que nos dedicamos a aprender
las reglas y realmente eso es eso es lo
que está sucediendo y tenemos que
empezar a conocer los diferentes
ambientes y cómo se comportan los
diferentes materiales y para eso estamos
los expertos no espero que que todos se
instruyan en esta corta plática que
están haciendo las marcas están firmando
datos para el 2025 de irse 100% reusable
y reciclable tú compostable estos ya son
pactos formales de las marcas que están
pensando toda la ecuación de la basura y
categorizan en tres cosas la red
usabilidad circuito cerrado la
reciclabilidad circuito cerrado y la
compostabilidad circuito cerrado a
través de la naturaleza eso es un poco
lo que está sucediendo
los consumidores llevan el cambio y
ahora vemos que las nuevas generaciones
más de un 72% están más dispuestos a
comprar un producto porque tiene una
plusvalía sostenible en el empaque o en
su cadena de suministro y esto es una
realidad y las marcas ya lo están viendo
y en algunos a sus los consultores dejan
de comprar productos porque tienen un
factor altamente contaminante o en la
cadena de empaque entonces ya empieza a
existir sea auditorías ciudadanas y lo
verás y entre bueno que está empacando
mi marca que tanto me gusta de refresco
quiero saber qué están haciendo qué está
pasando detrás eso ya sucede
cada vez son más los que se suman los
que se suman al movimiento de
organizaciones a nivel mundial empresas
a nivel mundial marcas y también algunas
caras conocidas que se han sumado a la
pelea del cambio climático y por
supuesto no podemos dejar afuera este
chapín destacado que también tiene un
grado de conciencia ambiental y social
y todo esto se ata al esfuerzo de la
humanidad
de el calentamiento global y este es el
rasgo el rango perdón en el que nos
estamos moviendo y este es el riesgo si
seguimos haciendo las cosas como la
estamos haciendo de un incremento de 1.5
grados a 4 y para que ustedes tengan el
rango es eso equivale a medio metro de
mar de subida de mar sobre toda la costa
a nivel mundial y si nos vamos a 4
grados son 9 metros hay una población de
500 millones de personas que estaría en
riesgo con esa subida del océano
entonces cuál es la visión de materiales
de reciclaje pero también agarremos con
materiales que se puedan reintegrar a
los suelos yo creo que ese es esa es la
parte que tenemos que empezar a entender
como humanidad para realmente dar un
mejor una mejor comunidad está en el
diálogo la problema manejo de esos
sólidos
y esta foto me gusta mucho porque da una
perspectiva que tierra no sólo hay una
y quiere bajar con una reflexión cuando
mil de grasa se preguntan y tú crees en
el calentamiento global
a él le gusta responder con otra
pregunta y dice
tú crees en la gravedad
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y